let's start with perhaps the most
important question will this make a
difference short answer yes it's a lot
of money and it will make a difference
to the average household i'm going to
show you just what we pay on our energy
bills going all the way back to the
1950s the higher this line is the
greater the proportion of our spending
that goes uh on energy and you can see
that it's been within this kind of light
blue area for most of recent history but
we're heading up aren't we that's where
we are at the moment here's where we
could go if those energy bills do go up
to 800 pounds which is what's expected
look we are higher potentially than any
other period that we know it's
unprecedented that's why the chancellor
is taking action now we already have
those measures that were introduced
earlier on this year the initial energy
rebate that brought down the potential
amount that we're going to be spending
on our bills but now on top of that we
have new money coming out from the
chancellor so doubling the energy rebate
extra measures as well and it brings it
down quite a lot so for the average
household you are talking about energy
bills still very high indeed but they
are not at those unprecedented levels
only the highest since perhaps the early
1980s but you know there what is an
average household it's worth just kind
of pointing out there are different
measures that apply to different income
groups and this is quite a
redistributive package so you've got
lots of money going to lower income
households pensioners as well you can
see that here i've broken down the
different parts of the chancellor's plan
you've got that energy bills bit there
low-income households 650 pounds one-off
payment for them pensioners disability
benefits as well household support fund
all of those dark blue bits are the
extra money that's being spent here the
red bar that's the windfall tax that's
basically the money coming in from those
oil companies and you've probably
noticed something the red bar is nowhere
near high enough to pay for all of those
blue bars put together i shall put them
together i'll stack them up so you can
see the the difference here that there
is a big gap there isn't there look all
of the spending comes to 15.3 billion
and in order to try and kind of bridge
that gap you're talking about the
chancellor borrowing an extra 10 billion
pounds he didn't like to talk about it
but he will have to borrow extra money
to pay for all of that stuff
and not just that because there was some
spending that wasn't costed out remember
he talked about operating benefits
operating pensions in line with
inflation inflation very high at the
moment here's what that does i'm going
to just kind of change the axis so that
that's the spending we've heard about
today here's what it could cost to
upgrade those benefits in line with
inflation if it's about 10
25 billion pounds so it could be an
enormous bit of spending with not much
revenue coming in it could be very
expensive indeed in fact this is bigger
than many budgets we've seen in recent
history but as far as the chancellor is
concerned all of this should be worth it